you want to talk about connie and julia
fox
yes
okay go
talk about it
the best way to get back at your ex
kanye's doing this to get back at his ex
yes right and i don't even know if he's
doing to get back at it but maybe he's
doing to like change public perception
about him because he was kind of getting
dragged yeah via kim's relationship yeah
right so now it's like the conversation
has been shifted to kanye and his
fake relationship yeah that he is
masquerading as um yeah he's going over
the top he's going over the top like mad
corny like bringing a photographer with
him but what's your honor to do you can
either be will smith and be like oh [ __ ]
super cooked or you go over the top and
be like i respect the kind of dude that
is a great way to look at the white girl
a fat dumper white girl with a fat
dumper is unstoppable there are white
girls with fat dumpers
that
for some reason are not
famous like they're satisfied just like
being on instagram or like like modeling
[ __ ] yoga pants or some [ __ ] yeah and
it's just like you know what you could
do
you're unstoppable yeah white girl fat
dumper unstoppable alex yeah for him for
sure absolutely they got their own point
category
um they do
fog
what is it
[ __ ] fat ass white bro pog there we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is pog
i think it's fat ass white girl but it's
spelled with ph
fat ass
white girl yeah yeah i got you yeah
according to the definition it's
offensive sexist term used to describe a
white woman who have who has a large
butt yeah
yeah what dumb [ __ ] with that
difference yeah
hey ass [ __ ] yeah bruh yeah i hate her
dog okay but this is why it's a great up
because it's it's just a younger kim
white girl fat dumper that's what kim
was it really is that kim got kids
[ __ ] disgusting i like i like them
that's lit no you're not a woman anymore
once you had kids now you're a mom you
know that's what i mean differently that
is over
but you don't think that you'll continue
to uh make love to your wife once you
guys are stopped already
let's go
no but you got the younger her that's
what i'm saying you got the new white
girl with the fat dumper kim we've been
seen now it's just like oh i got you but
yeah yeah but you gotta eat away your
eagle this is kanye doing it for him he
wants to know if he still got it he
takes uh he takes amber out the strip
club turns her into a star takes kim
from doing sex tapes where ray j turns
her into a stuff so he took the movie
star and turned her into it but she's
still like she's not a white girl with a
dumper she's not up now she wasn't up
there yet that's a great point and he
wants to know if he could still do and
it's crazy because it's happening yep
this girl to an interviewer oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and yeah this is kind of why
i'm just saying he could have probably
you know had a bigger transformation
than a girl that's already in movies not
that she's famous but there's something
you know i mean he got a really nah but
nobody made a black girl famous yeah
nobody was talking about her no he's
talking about now people yeah of course
yeah so
he's
ultimate stroke to ego like he's
crazy
yeah that is actually impressive
it's not even about the girls about if
he could make it if he could still do it
that's that's what i was always saying
about the maga hat it's like can i make
this cool
[ __ ] black rain rain boots cool yeah
people like that
boots them like uh the ones that look
like a bubble jacket yeah those are fire
i would wear them shits you know what
i'm talking about i would not
not most i'll say most i would say most
i think he was missing for a minute bro
he was missing for just when he was on
that uh maga hat [ __ ] i wasn't rocking
his stuff but yeah it's still kind of
it's heat you like the maggot
you was into the maggot a little bit
well not his though had like the cool
brim yeah yeah yeah and a patch on the
side yeah
that's what i tell you whenever i rock
the maggot what do you do i got another
kanye one that's cool yeah yeah
yeah man okay so this is the superflex
and this is what it is he found the
perfect thing to fit his ego and
everybody's talking about it there's so
much attention he's happier than he's
ever been he's about to drink drop fire
music do you think he's gonna be
inspired i hope so yeah
still he might still be too religious so
yeah but yeah donde he was supposed to
be hungry again and it didn't really
there was there was trash
but it wasn't life of pablo that's true
that's true you know it's interesting
like hearing the the girl julia fox talk
about like their dates these interviews
are so funny like one of the ones is
like
and then after dinner we went back to
the hotel and and he had uh gotten all
these clothes into the hotel my whole
room with clothes i didn't even know how
he did it and it's like you don't know
how he got clothing into a hotel
have you ever traveled before
have you ever traveled with clothing so
he just pre-planned it because he like
landed that day so he like landed yeah
went straight to
dinner or whatever the case is and then
like oh alex i know nah but she i i just
pointed out the fact that he just
touched down that day and then had all
this hope had all that [ __ ] yeah yeah
like he's not kanye [ __ ] west yeah
yeah how does a billionaire who's in
charge of a clothing company get such a
thing done yeah i mean
it's seamless it's kind of i get sushi
to my apartment in 30 minutes i can't
get four sweaters to hang on a wreck son
how do you do that sushi yeah you never
done seamless i've i've heard of it i
think come on bro hey priority delivery
dog do that [ __ ] dollar yeah door dash
bro they got it man they're worth it
mm-hmm yeah he's trying sometimes
he still gets home-cooked meals for this
guy oh that's right
for now we'll see we'll see i keep
trying to keep that going yeah buying
equipment and [ __ ] i got a pasta maker
i'm like
yeah
yeah that's good keep it moving bro yeah
anyway so yay so what do you think the
next move is you don't think he's
actually going to marry her there's no
real
yeah and do you think it's possible that
like they could be both so addicted to
clout that they believe in their
relationship
so like um
and this is maybe a little tie back like
the tom brady a b thing it's like
i think tom brady and i think i think ab
are friends and ab brought up this thing
where he's like uh i mean why am i a
friend because i'm good at football and
it's like yeah yeah
and if that's the only reason why you
guys are still friends after knowing
each other for a year
that's on you
like you could have developed other
things he had you in his house yeah like
y'all live together
you couldn't form a real connection
watch some [ __ ] country western
movies or some [ __ ] like have something
else that you have connected yeah on
right like so
what i'm here but it is totally normal
if two people are passionate about the
same thing that they could be friends
right yeah i mean like the the shittiest
version of this is obviously like drug
addicts but like you see it i think a
lot of times with your passions comedy
like there's a lot of people that are
friends because of comedy and they share
a passion the most important things of
their lives and then if they both quit
comedy they might not be homies no more
yeah so i wonder if they actually both
believe that they like each other
because they're both getting fed with so
much positive attention which is the
real thing that they're addicted to like
a crackhead couple who really believes
they're in love but in reality they're
both just out here trying to get that
crack
so i'm i'm like does it start to morph
your feelings right like will the girl
start going i think i actually really
like him yeah and will kanye start going
nah i'm really feeling this girl maybe
i'm feeling so filled
by this other stuff in my life i think
this is yeah i don't i think it's just
complete revenge
she kim dumped him he's begging to have
her back in concerts yeah she with pete
davidson this young [ __ ] kid who
already [ __ ] everybody he's eaten all
the negative pr she's getting all the
good pr and he's like oh you don't think
two could play at this game
we can go yeah i'll [ __ ] i have
threesomes in [ __ ] hotels i'll get
with this girl i'll live it up you must
have forgot i'm richer than you bro you
know what's crazy
i kind of did like three different black
girls and nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah
one white girl bro with a fat ass
the entire internet is on fire did you
notice that no like he was on dates yeah
a few black chicks nobody said anything
he had a hotel two two black shorties
came out the room there was a picture
people say yeah don't even mention their
names that's one white guy is like
fabricated that like he's putting out
all the stories he's like pushing all
the narrative that he wants he got to be
oh yeah and that's why he's just
selecting the girls that he's trying to
yeah he's working out the joke it's like
what tag works what punchline white girl
fat ass all right let me go back to the
well yeah like he tried out the sisters
and then the internet didn't run for it
one white girl with a fat ass yeah
front page he's like an impressions
comic that's just
you try to do these jokes but it's like
through that christopher walken
[Applause]
you